welcome to exploring computing
today's video is introduction to html
hypertext markup language so in the last
lecture we saw the origins of the world
wide web
and we spent some time understanding
what hypertext means and previously
in the last lecture we took a look at
http which is a hypertext transport
protocol
we're going to begin this lecture by
considering what the relationship
between
the http protocol and the html hypertext
markup languages
and then we're actually going to study
how html actually works
and in the following video we're going
to get some hands-on practice using html
by the end of these two videos you
should be able to make your own web
pages
let's start off with a quick review from
last lecture so you recall that http
stands for hypertext transfer protocol
and this is a protocol that governs
how two computers on the world wide web
interact
and so a computer can make a request to
a web server
asking for a particular file and the web
server will respond by sending the file
the files actually can have any one of
the number of formats
the most common is probably the html
file which was what we're going to be
talking about in this lecture but
cascading stylesheet files or css files
are also
quite common and we'll study that in the
next lecture and of course the image
files that we've talked about in
our second lecture of the quarter are
also
commonly used and it turns out that http
does not actually specify the formats of
any of these files
http simply tells two computers on the
web
how one computer can send a request to
another computer
asking for a file to be sent back it
does not specify
the format of the files themselves and
so there are many other types of files
that could be sent by the worldwide web
such as
video files and again in fact you could
come up with new file types and http
doesn't really care what the file types
are
it's just designed so that one computer
can request a particular file
of the other computer without regard to
what the internal format of that file
is now html stands for hypertext markup
language and as i
suggested it is the most common file
format so that's what we're going to
take a look at now
and it is a key file format and any web
page on the world wide web needs to have
an html file in addition to whatever
other files are included
so html as i've suggested stands for
hypertext markup language and we've seen
what hypertext means from the last
lecture
and language more or less refers to what
you'd expect
and it turns out that computer languages
have many similarities with human
languages they have their own grammar
they have their vocabulary
they're not that different from french
or japanese or whatever other
human languages that you've learned but
this other part
markup we haven't talked about that so
let's talk a little bit about markup and
what that all means so the term markup
comes from publishing
so what i have here is i have a
worldwide webpage
from the stanford daily so one question
to ask
is did the author of this particular
article
make decisions like whether or not a
particular photo should appear in the
article
or whether the caption appearing
underneath the photo should appear in
with a light gray background if the date
of the article
should appear in sans-serif font in
light gray or if that first
sentence in the article was written in
bold
so i've not talked to the particular
author of this article george chen
but i have talked to other stanford
daily writers and they tell me that
that's not how it works and in fact
that's not traditionally how it would
work
in publishing so that's not really a
surprise
so typically what's going to happen is
the author is just going to write the
text of the article
and then somebody else say an editor
will go in
and make decisions on what sort of
formatting
should appear in the article so we could
say oh i want this first section up here
this title i wanted to appear in bold 24
point
font and maybe i want that
byline underneath it to appear in sans
serif font
we'll talk about what sans serif means
in another lecture if you're not
familiar with the term
and then i want to go ahead and insert a
photo in there so these are all
decisions that somebody other than the
author would make
and traditionally the editor would
actually
write these comments down using what's
called markup so what i've done here is
i've
marked up the original text from the
author providing
markup comments that will be used by
whoever does
the type setting for the publishing
and so this is really what html is all
about
so in html we're going to use this form
of markup
in order to tell the computer how to
display their web pages
so let's take a look at html
we've seen what hypertext is we've just
learned what markup is
and this is a language and i'll be
talking in another lecture a little bit
more closely about
the similarities and differences between
human languages and computer languages
it turns out an awful lot of what drives
html though is this concept
of markup that we've just gone over
so let's say we want to create a web
page that says go stanford and we want
the go to appear in italics and stanford
to appear in bold
if i were working with a human type
setter i could just go ahead and do my
scrawled markup using a pen like this
but that's not gonna work with a
computer computers are getting better at
reading handwritten stuff but we're not
really quite there yet
so this is what it's gonna look like in
html basically i'm providing the same
information that i would
to a human type setter but i'm going to
do it in a more formal manner that's
easier for the computer to process
what we're seeing here these are what
are referred to as tags
the tags often work in pairs so i have a
start tag
and an end tag where the end tag is the
same as a start tag except for has a
slash in front of it
we also talk about these as elements so
the element consists of the start tag
the end tag and whatever goes between
the start and end tag
here i have an i element which stands
for an italics element and a b
element which stands for bold element
and in fact
the key to learning how html works is to
learn all the different tags
this is actually a fairly large subset
of the tags
and we'll be providing you with a list
of tags that you can look over
there really aren't that many tags so
what i recommend is at some point
you either look through the list that
we'll be providing you which is
probably the vast majority of the tags
that are used in widespread use
or you look at an official list which is
a bit bigger than the list i'll be
providing you with
and just get a sense of what the tags
that are that are out there
you don't need to memorize the tags but
you do want to have some familiarity
with what's available and then
when you need a particular tag you're
like oh i want to create a bold at least
you'll remember oh i
seem to recall there's a there's a tag
for that and you can go ahead and look
it up
we sometimes refer to the elements as
containers
and in this particular case i have the
italics element
and then you can see that the bold
element contains
both the italics element as well as the
word stanford
you do need to maintain this containing
relationship so if i try and mix the two
as shown here
that actually turns out to be illegal so
don't do that
an element must be completely contained
within another element we can't have an
element partially containing an element
sometimes the tags themselves don't
provide sufficient information we need
to add additional information
suppose i wanted to link the word
stanford here to the actual stanford
website
it turns out that the tag used to link
from one website to another is the a tag
which stands for anchor
but i need to provide additional
information telling
what the website i'm linking to is and
so
here i've added in what's called an
attribute value pair
the ahrefs stands for hypertext
reference and i'm providing the anchor
tag with additional information
telling it where the anchor is linked to
some tags don't actually work in pairs
so suppose i want to create a line break
a line break is going to allow me to
basically have a character turn in the
middle of a line
i could have a line break start tech and
line break end tag but that doesn't make
a huge amount of sense
and so this particular tag can be done
without a start and end tag and i'm
going to indicate that using a closing
slash as shown here one thing that
you'll notice if you start trying to
create these web pages is that it turns
out that
if you put character turns or spaces
or tabs into a document
those actually all get combined into a
single space
so basically what html is going to do is
it's going to take
any what it's referred to as white space
so in computer science
we refer to white space we're talking
about any of the
characters which can create blank space
on a web page that includes the
character turns
the tabs and the spaces it will take all
the white space you enter
and it will just treat it as a single
space so here
i've said go stanford in my source
that's in my source html
i put in a couple carriage returns i put
in another go cardinal put in a couple
character turns
and then when it's actually gets
displayed it's as if those character
turns or any tabs i entered or whatever
i entered it's just going to be treated
as a single space
so what's the solution here well it
turns out that there is a
special tag which i need to use
in order to get these to appear in
paragraphs so there's a paragraph
tag and so i go ahead and create two
paragraph elements here
you may be wondering what the
relationship between the paragraph tag
is and the line break tag we saw earlier
notice these paragraphs
have a blank line between them if i were
to use a line break
as i show here there is no blank line
between
the two lines so the line break
does create a carriage return between
the two lines but it does not create a
blank line
whereas the paragraph typically will
create
a blank line between the two paragraphs
although we'll see next lecture when we
start learning cascading style sheets
you can
actually control exactly what the
paragraph tag does if you want the
paragraph tag create
two blank lines great go ahead and do it
if you want the paragraph
tag to create no blank lines you could
do that as well we'll learn about that
next lecture
also notice because
html doesn't care about extra white
space
if i have the line break tag followed by
a carriage return
that creates the web page we've seen
here but if i don't have a carriage
return
and i just have it all in one line i get
the exact same result
another tag that's pretty useful is the
h1
tag it's used to create a heading and so
h1 is the most important heading but
there's actually
six different types of headings with h1
being the most important
and h6 being the least important you may
be wondering at this point what if i
want to set the foreground or background
color of my text
or what if i want to change the font or
how can i control alignment and have it
right aligned or left aligned or center
aligned
and it turns out that while once upon a
time we did do this with html
we no longer do it with html we now do
it using cascading style sheets
and this is a legacy of our
physics past so remember html was
originally created for
physics papers and they really didn't
need that much formatting
but modern web pages are created by
graphic artists and other media
professionals and they want a lot more
control
so we've taken a lot of the
simple formatting that was available in
the original html for physics papers and
we've actually moved it to second
language called cascading style sheets
which i'll talk about next lecture
in addition to tags which we've gone
over which structure
the web page itself there's some
additional tags
which you need to provide for all web
pages
and what you're seeing here is here's
some additional tags that
are needed to have a well formatted html
file
up at the top i've got the doctype
this is a bit of an odd tag and it
doesn't really follow
the syntax rules of the other tags you
can see it starts off with the
exclamation point
it has a capital doctype it's standalone
but does not having an ending slash
you do need to include this although as
you can see from my little comment here
it's mostly not used anymore
but you do need to include it it used to
specify
all sorts of things like hey this is
html4
this is xhtml1 and
we'll talk a bit later but the web
browser manufacturers are trying to get
rid of all the version numbers
however if you do not have the version
at all it turns out
that this is going to cause the web
browser to think that you have a really
really old web page
create it back before the doctype tag
was included and it will throw your web
browser into a weird mode called
quarks mode and you don't want that to
happen
so even though i'm just specifying the
dog type as html instead of
html4 html5 xhtml1
you still do need to provide the doctype
so don't forget that otherwise you may
get some
really weird looking web pages
okay so there's an html start and end
tag that surrounds everything and then i
have this head section and body section
so let's take a look at those
the head section provides information
about the web page and the body section
provides the actual contents of the web
page
let's take a closer look at that head
section you can see that the head
section includes
the character encoding and this is what
we talked about the first lecture where
we talked about ascii
we talked about iso 8859 which allowed
us to do something like western european
eastern european cyrillic
and a couple other things all fitting
into a single byte
and then we talked about unicode and so
this is where you're going to specify
what sort of encoding your html source
file is using
and then there's a title and the title
is what appears on the tab in the web
browser and notice from
this image here that the title does not
actually appear on the web page itself
so in this case i've used the title
title for tab
and notice title for tab does not
actually appear
in the actual contents of the webpage it
only appears
on the tab of the web browser so this
sort of emphasizes what i mentioned
earlier
the head is things about the web page
it's not the actual web page contents
and we'll see throughout our study of
html and css that there's a variety of
different information that goes into the
head so for now it seems pretty simple
but we will be adding some extra
information into this section
and then the body is whatever actually
appears on the web page itself
there are a number of different versions
of html as i alluded to
a bit earlier the current version of
html is html5
but as i suggested the web browser
manufacturers
are not super happy with version numbers
i think one of the things that's going
on is they don't like having specific
version numbers and then people pointing
at them
saying hey you are not fully supporting
this
version so this is a reason why we've
gotten rid of the version numbers in the
doctype
in addition to just the different
versions numbers like
html 3.2 html4
html 4.1 xhtml1
there are several variants of html the
variant that i'm using is called xhtml
and xhtml has a set of more formal rules
than
standard html so for example standard
html if i were to write head for the
head section i could write it in
lowercase i could write it in all caps i
could even
mix the casing having a capital h a
lowercase e
and uppercase a and a lowercase d and
those would all be legal
in xhtml they're like wait wait wait
this is out of hand
please write your tags in lowercase
letters
that closing slash that i had on the
line break
that's actually not necessary in html
but i use it because
i like the students when they see that
i've written a tag that has
only a tag instead of a pair with a
start tag and an end tag
i like them to see that slash at the end
and realize immediately
oh that's a standalone tag this is not
part of a pair
and then finally is another example
between xhtml and standard html
xhtml requires that all attribute value
pairs
have the value in quotes whereas
html has a bunch of different rules for
whether or not quotes are necessary
so basically the xhtml variant i'm using
is just going to lead to more uniform
looking code and
i would strongly recommend that you use
it for your code
i think it's actually quite common
probably amongst professional web pages
it's used more often than not
all right so that's our little
introduction to html
in the next video we're going to take
you on a hands-on look on how to
actually create an
html file and how to
to load into web browse and how to test
it i'll talk to you soon